bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors on va à
contextualiser concrètement le
chiffrement de bout en bout c'est quoi
message vous êtes en train de créer sur
votre ordinateur ou téléphone portable
et de transmettre ce message chiffré à
travers internet pour que à l'autre bout
du fil une votre interlocuteur lui le
des chiffres localement sur sa machine
ce qui fait que si on intercepte ce
message on ne peut absolument pas faire
sens de ce qu'on attend c'est le chiffre
et c'est complètement lisible c'est
comme ça que fonctionne aujourd'hui la
quasi-totalité des messageries qui sont
mis petit à petit adopté ce chiffrement
de bout en bout des messageries très
populaires comme moi de sa poule
télégramme à des choses un peu plus
confidentielles ou utilisés par en bas
d'hier des niches comme par exemple
signal ou tout un tas d'autres messages
rire vide scred qui permettent d'assurer
une totale confidentialité des échanges
donc ça veut dire qu'actuellement il n'y
a aucun moyen pour que les autorités
accède à ce type de message si bien sûr
vous pouvez si vous cibler des individus
très précis attaqué leur smartphone ou
leur ordinateur prend en prendre le
contrôle à leur insu et accéder aux
messages une fois qu'ils ont été
déchiffrés blessés des opérations qui
sont compliqués et puis qu'ils ne
peuvent permettre à permettre de faire
ça de façon massive et à chaque fois ça
nécessite une attaque spécifique sur une
personne là il s'agit de passer à
l'échelon supérieur c'est-à-dire de se
donner les moyens pour les services de
renseignement et probablement pour
d'autres choses d'accéder à n'importe
quel terminal de n'importe quelle
personne pour voir les messages
déchiffrer alors est ce que pour lutter
contre le terrorisme
c'est en tout cas ce que dit ce projet
de loi est-ce qu'il faut justement ce
genre de texte qui permettrait aux
services de renseignement d'accéder à
nos messages
est ce que c'est une nécessité
aujourd'hui on regarde ce qui s'est
passé au regard de ce qui s'est passé
prenons par exemple le bataclan la
coordination des assaillants du bataclan
a été fait par sms
donc il n'y a pas moins chiffré que les
sms c'est particulièrement facile à
intercepter et ça ne les a pas empêchés
de se coordonner avec cette technologie
finalement très primitive donc au jour
d'aujourd'hui il semblerait que l'on
n'ait pas besoin de chiffrement bouton
ceci dit bien évidemment qu'il ya des
activités criminelles dont le terroriste
qui tire parti de ce chiffrement but
par contre il est assez évident que si
demain cette confidentialité n'est plus
assurée ces criminels qui sont pas plus
bêtes que vous et moi iront passer à
d'autres technologies qui leur
assureront ce site ce type de sécurité
et puis si on commence par ce genre de
lois pour déchiffrer ce que ce sera pas
seulement que le début alors non
seulement ça ne sera que le début parce
que le concept de terrorisme est assez
élastique et la hrira indéniablement
dans les années qui viennent pour
s'étendre à d'autres catégories
mais ça n'est qu'une partie du problème
parce que l'idée c'est d'installer ce
qu'on appelle des backdoors est à dire
quelque part de donner un accès
privilégié à votre téléphone portable
aux services de renseignement européens
le problème c'est que le jour où cet
accès privilégié ce passage secret est
révélé
n'importe qui peut s'en saisir aussi
bien une puissance étrangère qu une
organisation criminelle et à partir de
là on est face à un très très gros
problèmes de sécurité ça s'est déjà
posée par le passé des bacs d'eau
abandonnés saaq été révélée publiquement
et qui ont été instrumentalisés pour
faire tout à fait autre chose par des
gens qui étaient évidemment pas des
alliés d'années ça alors projet de loi
pour l'instant est ce que ça a des
chances de passer
c'est très difficile à dire d'abord
parce que il n'ya pas l'unanimité
absolue en europe pour faire passer ce
genre de projet de loi c'est pas la
première fois qu'il ya c'est ce genre de
tentatives bernard cazeneuve a tenté de
pousser cette idée il ya quelques années
et puis ensuite il s'agit d'un bras de
fer avec des entreprises sont
surpuissantes je pense notamment à
facebook et qui elle même auront un
poids géopolitique qui sont ciblés dans
des situations très délicates aux états
unis avec la victoire de joe biden donc
on est dans un jeu de bras de fer qui va
être une triangulation entre l'europe
les états unis et facebook
ça va être très intéressant à observer
on peut d'ores et déjà remarqué que à
l'heure actuelle facebook n'est pas dans
une position de force ce qui était son
cahier encore quelques temps merci en
tout cas monsieur epelboin d'avoir été
avec nous je répète que vous êtes
enseignant à sciences po et spécialiste
des réseaux sociaux merci